foreign
[Music]
okay great thank you here we go five
four three two one
everything is good okay great thank you
[Music]
thank you
I guess I have nothing here
I had rookie six immediately
foreign
[Music]
the traditional purse game okay Baku
Boulevard
[Music]
I'll probably take care
and you can play Knight B3 but
[Music]
midnight of 694
I think I can do this
foreign
[Music]
oh my gosh
thank you
choke this
[Music]
foreign
I don't really want to take and give up
the bishop here
laughs
I'm sure what to do here
[Music]
all right here we go
all right one night bd7 that's annoying
okay let's keep the Bishops
[Music]
okay if he takes it off I'll take
three and H5 by 400 piece
foreign
[Music]
be able to win this one pretty
straightforwardly
[Music]
hang up six we can be two queen h8
and I'm one of the queen here that's the
one thing
very important
when you won King H2
[Music]
I don't know why I did that
but this is an easy flag
also there's a queen trade in a win
my technique has left something to be
desired but
Pablo zarnage key or zarniki
darniki
on each key
I guess the Polish last name aniki but
he's he's Latin American
[Music]
and I don't like what I got here I did
the opening gotta mix it up
I don't know why I did that either
[Music]
laughs
my Bishop is in prison that's the only
big issue
you gotta go G5 for now
I don't know why but all right
oh he takes the Rook I didn't see that
just gotta play for the clock here
[Music]
okay this is an easy flag
not the way I wanted to win okay all
right
not sure what this is but what
foreign
[Music]
I I went for it at the wrong moment
wow
[Music]
I should probably go King G8
oh man
[Music]
foreign
lucky as usual
okay that that literally had zero chance
of working
I went F3 okay I thought it would go
night after spring
thank you
[Music]
all right got him
thank you
foreign
C6 and queen E7 makes sense here
[Music]
yeah I'm not playing the swell
oh I took the fun I wasn't expecting
I'm in Knight D6 I don't know
you're losing
foreign
[Music]
maybe I should go on A5 but he's lagging
he's lagging
her again
Queen before
thank you
foreign
of course
[Music]
oh man
thank you
[Music]
you can chill
foreign
[Music]
I don't know if this works or not but I
gotta try
[Music]
see
foreign
[Music]
thank you
okay
come in
[Music]
not sure why I'm playing this setup
695 got to be very careful here
let's sack The Exchange
[Music]
wow
I'm gonna lose this
[Music]
thank you
yeah he held it nice job
[Music]
a little careful here
foreign
[Music]
sometimes I look at the play of these
people I'm like oh how's this guy 2700
[Music]
session flagon or at least one
wow
[Music]
now I gotta be very careful
foreign
[Music]
that was tough that was tough game
penguin
[Music]
sure why I forgot I forgot what I played
against him in our
foreign
[Music]
I'm Leonard
100 piece
nicely done
yeah I forget what I played against him
so I he I played some lines of force him
to play the fiancado
that's not a move
foreign
[Music]
pretty incredible
pretty okay but there's a piece
as soon as I started saying pretty
incredibly blunted all of his pieces and
resigns literally wanted all these
pieces
I mean that was a pretty good play you
got his Knight to D6 and stuff but then
he just chokes
board Nick I wonder who Hikaru is
getting I really am curious
I should have gone
and very experienced in these positions
it should be able to win
[Music]
no oh my gosh my mouth slipped
yeah my mouth slipped oh my gosh that's
annoying
and I have no moves wait maybe I have
this one
yeah that was an annoying mile slope
if it happens
oh my gosh oh my gosh I didn't wasn't
paying attention to what he was doing
either that Mouse lip really unsettled
me
oh
the winning position
[Music]
s
can I do that
foreign
thank you
what is worse here
[Music]
I don't stay away from to trap my room
bye
[Music]
going on
foreign
[Music]
we already had this
and I'm losing a piece
actually pretty unbelievable that I
can't save the piece here maybe I can't
even go like this type of thing
[Music]
give me some counter play
ER of Queen C7
women
[Music]
three winning Carl
thank you
[Music]
Knight G4 he has to play only moves
doesn't see it
lucky there that he went into a line
that I knew decently
I'm sick of the queen
boros
yeah but it was a rook
bad play he plays domain I'm pretty sure
they just resigned dude
[Music]
seriously Dennis
man I'm telling you man
Jesus Louise's there we go
I mean are you disgusted by your
position you just I wouldn't want to
play this
again on this guy
[Music]
well
I had a three I can take and go Bishop
B5
[Music]
foreign
yeah this position is probably bad for
black
eggs I'll take here
x91
I think I can get away with it
foreign
[Music]
okay she's seriously gonna let his time
run out really
very classy
foreign
coach again
I'm already winning
gotta be accurate here
which I was not just okay
oh crap I missed FG
um here
I'll just take it
I don't know hit him again
put an end to this
forgot to play
it
[Music]
foreign
happy with the drum more than happy to
commit harakiri
is because it cuts away his streak Anna
Cuts away mine but I think I can win
games faster looks okay
[Music]
um
thank you
[Music]
foreign
simple position
somehow
[Music]
um
I'm playing poorly
he offers me a drama to play
I'm honored
[Music]
yeah rough
okay enough
[Music]
the guy knows she's stuck here
I mean if somebody has to beat a car
because he's already on the six he won
two games in the span that I won one
[Music]
thank you
I don't plan to stop winning but
foreign
[Music]
I gotta go for it here
man but I have nothing there's they have
nothing to do here
okay big some points quickly then
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
I can think I see
oh no
[Music]
okay gotta win like a couple more here
to be safe
oh of course they paired me with the guy
we keep losing to him
[Music]
what how does this work
I'm trying my best here not to not choke
this the same way
I'm winning
and see it
I need him to resign foreign
[Music]
I think for seconds
on that
um D4 six weeks if maybe the risky move
but I want to win this game
foreign
[Music]
oh no under the pawn oh my gosh I wanted
me
or wait maybe no me
maybe I made him
thank you
okay with one minute left let's see if I
can get one more in
foreign
[Music]
yeah I mean I'm gonna be winning but I'm
not on the Block here
after the Drone obviously not gonna take
it I mean I don't want to lose rating
for nothing
but it's gonna stall out good game
all right here we go that's it
ggs everybody
your car does does cling to second
yeah he called his Queen to Second
penguin and third board thinking fourth
yeah all right
um Let me let me show you the standings
I'm I'm proud that I went like 4-1
against you Carl
no no it's only title players somebody
was asking thank you for the 50 Subs I
really appreciate it
yeah I'm I'm happy that at this time I
actually finished with a streak normally
I start losing toward the end
but this time I made sure that I mean I
kept kept your car at arm's length
um which was good yeah against the car I
think I went four and a half one and a
half thank you Benjamin Gibson to GMP
Carl I won four and a half one and a
half
disco yeah but everybody gets nervous at
the end it's not just me it's it's just
it's hard not to get nervous at the end
because here you can sense that the win
is at hand
I think your car also gets nervous at
the end
but this time I was able to keep it at
Bay
yeah I could feel that I was under
hikara's skin I mean I could just feel
it you know sometimes you can feel that
you have have someone in the bag I knew
it when when I beat him in the jabala
that that is just like an
uncharacteristic loss from Hikaru
um he doesn't lose like this so but I
know all these ideas like these types of
positions that we studied with Bortnick
so I know this queen H4 Bishop G5 idea
for instance
no the record was set by Hikaru last
week it was like 315 or something
I lost the first game which is kind of
interesting and then I
then I started beating him the other
turning point was that game I won in the
exchange because we were tied
we were tied and then this was I think
the most important game in the brawl is
at this point I had lost like two out of
three or something like like that
but I know this line too I mean I
studied this so he made a mistake here
allowing h6259 F6
thank you oh thank you God I appreciate
it I will be finishing soon but
appreciate the raid yeah great success
against me yeah well but this is not
title Tuesday right this is more
Instinct play
and on instincts I think my King's
Indian understanding is no worse than
his
um to be completely honest especially
with black so
this is just a very very nice all-around
game I don't think I made any mistakes
yeah and of course he helped me out by
wondering the night
yeah I got lucky in a lot of games too
even the game against arabid say that
that
this game was a disaster because I was
completely winning
and then suddenly I've learned the
screen A2 move
and here she could have she could have
forced a draw
he or she could have forced a draw by
taking
and then going Queen A3 check
oh no she can't because I have Knight F7
oh very interesting
very interesting so I actually could
have kept the game going
I'm definitely not the best museum
player in the world but I'll take it how
many games did I lose my overall score
was 73 out of 81. nothing crazy I I lost
quite a few points
what's up Lily yeah yeah you played
amazing honestly Thank You Wiz 28 for
the 32 months you were out playing me
you were genuinely outplaying me
um
yeah and I think at some point you had
yeah I almost missed Bishop D3 that
would have lost the game wow apparently
I had this move thank you stress gifting
to Argos three
um yes I was getting outplayed
and then at some point I think you just
lost the thread
somewhere around here I think it's
already kind of difficult to play
um happens to Bullet the game the game's
just uh swing so quickly
um
let's see who did I'm curious what kind
of pairing sicaro got
like who was he losing to he lost a
Jasper he lost to a mean tabai
yeah Jasmine I only got Jocelyn once so
I was very very lucky that I only got
Jasmine once Hikaru was getting pretty
difficult parents he got at one point he
got whoa he got mehmedov and then 2900.
he got a 3 000 and then a moment of 2900
2900 Joss from me
and then I mean to have it a blind he
beat all of them
is there a titled Arena
no there's no title Arena I think
are your parents Hardware he cars I mean
listen if you really want to you can you
can average the rating
but
um I I don't think I got easy pairings I
mean I I was getting pretty consistent
like good players
um I got for instance the beginning was
easy I got three easy pairings and then
I got my Med of 12 team Amin Bortnick
Panda Hikaru come on I got very tough
pairings Min Hikaru blitzstream Angel
Jasper
no I got very tough bearings today
definitely I got very tough bearings
today like I there were some stretches
when I
when I when I when I had some easier
games but
overall it was it was definitely a tough
one
yeah when I got to First it you know it
starts giving you some easier pairings
but you still gotta beat them
yeah it's bullet brawl sometimes you get
easier parents sometimes you get harder
player I played better than he did in
this tournament that's why I won
no that's not true whoever wins is the
person who plays the better chess not
the person who gets the easier pairings
that's who wins
because the pairings are all
approximately let's be real all
approximately the same
yes Tariq we both got easy pairings I'm
sure you would have gotten 73 out of 81
against that field
of I mean by Hikaru Jasper Bortnick
um like 600 other GM's
very easy pairings yes
yeah I think when you get on a street
that also gives you better prints also
it just gives you more confidence it
just gives you more confidence
no I'm just setting the record straight
I would say the pairings were average as
well
well I am just like to play bullet and I
played well today
thanks everybody goodbye
foreign
[Music]